joe biden a voulu donner l'image d'un
président des ja la tâche dès hier soir
lorsqu'on l'a vu en train de prendre ses
quartiers dans la maison blanche
notamment au sein du bureau vallée
justement sur son bureau une pile de
décret comme pour montrer qu'il n'y a
pas de temps à perdre c'est d'ailleurs
ce qu'avait twitté joe biden quelques
minutes seulement après son investiture
parmi les mesures prises par le nouveau
président des états unis la plupart
visent clairement à effacer un certain
nombre de politiques engagées par
l'administration trump sur des
thématiques telles que le climat
l'immigration ou encore l'économie on
écoute les premiers mots de joe biden
depuis le bureau ovale à la maison
blanche compte tenu de l'état que de la
nation il n'y a pas de temps à perdre il
faut se mettre au travail immédiatement
nous l'avons déjà annoncé nous allons
signer un certain nombre de décrets dans
la semaine et je vais commencer
aujourd'hui les tweets sur la crise
combinée du président du comice 19 et de
la crise économique qui a suivi et sur
la crise climatique et les questions
d'équité raciale certaines des mesures
exécutive que je vais signer aujourd'hui
vont contribuer à inverser le cours de
la crise dope le vide et nous allons
combattre le changement climatique comme
nous ne l'avons jamais fait jusqu'ici et
faire progresser les kits et raciales et
soutenir les autres communautés
desservi nous allons également
reconstruire notre économie joe biden a
également prévu une série de mesures
pour lutter contre la pandémie de kovy
19/100 administration souhaite renforcer
les restrictions sanitaires et surtout
répandre le port du masque dans le pays
la journée de ce jeudi doit justement
permettre à l'administration byden
d'élaborer une stratégie pour lutter
contre cette pandémie de kobe de 19
autres chantiers pour joe biden tenter
de réconcilier l'amérique divisée
évidemment l'opposition est déjà forte
contre les mesures engagées par baï
donne les mesures sur l'immigration sont
contestés mais ce qui a provoqué le plus
de réactions c'est le fait que je baille
donne et fait réintégrer les états unis
dans les accords de paris sur le climat
écouté par exemple la réaction de tête
cruz sénateur républicain du texas est
proche
donald trump en signant ce décret le
président biden montrent qu'ils
s'intéressent plus aux opinions des
citoyens de paris qu aux emplois des
citoyens de pittsburgh rejoindre la
corde paris ne consiste pas à restaurer
le leadership américain à l'étranger ou
à résoudre la crise climatique mais il
s'agit plutôt des projets des démocrates
de détruire les emplois qu'ils n'aiment
pas y compris des milliers d'emplois
dans le secteur manufacturier et perdre
le contrôle de nos énergies futures
le procureur général du texas a déjà
fait savoir qu'il pourrait même lancer
des procédures en justice contre les
politiques mises en place par joe biden
certaines organisations texane craignent
justement les répercussions de la
politique environnementale engagée par
le nouveau président des états unis sur
l'économie de cet état très liés à
l'exploitation des ressources naturelles
du côté des supporters donald trump
forcément la déception est grande dans
leurs rangs sur les réseaux sociaux
certains espéraient encore un ultime
retournement de situation lors de la
cérémonie d'investiture qui n'a
finalement pas eu lieu il ya eu quelques
petits rassemblements ces derniers jours
de la part de supporters de donald trump
notamment devant les capitals un certain
nombre d'états américains
beaucoup de supporters de l'ancien
locataire de la maison blanche continue
de penser que l'élection leur a été
volée et qu'il rejette donc la
légitimité du nouveau président joe
biden la plupart rejette évidemment
aussi les
surprise par le nouveau locataire de la
maison blanche et les regards se
tournent désormais vers la floride
là où séjourne actuellement donald trump
la question est de savoir ce qu'a prévu
l'ancien président des états unis il se
dit ici qu'il pourrait monter un parti
le patriote parties en vue de rester en
politique et pourquoi pas lisez
l'élection présidentielle de 2000 24 ce
qui est sûr c'est que parmi lesquels que
74 millions d'électeurs de donald trump
beaucoup continuent à le soutenir alors
vous l'aurez compris malgré les appels à
l'unité nationale lancé lors de la
cérémonie d'investiture par joe biden la
réconciliation de l'amérique diviser ce
n'est pas pour tout de suite